he showed me
[Music]
hey
[Music]
i worry about everybody i don't worry
only about my family i mean it's
difficult to how how to explain it to
people that
in the in this situation it's probably
all ukrainian people feel the same we
don't feel pain only for our families we
feel pain for all our people for all our
country
and this is the biggest pain
imagine this you one day you have life
you have plans you plan the festival you
plan books
and then
at some point you are in a bomb shelter
like this
[Music]
hello
we are ukrainians living in new york
and we are desperate to ask people to
help ukraine to fight because they are
just alone they're supporting but
actually not supporting
we won't really support country because
they are weak it's small country we
never wanted war and we have our
relatives our mothers children and
grandchildren there
why are you here today i'm here because
my friends in ukraine are fighting and
dying for their homeland
amid the most destructive
nonsensical evil invasion since the end
of world war
two we came here to protest against
russian aggression against the sovereign
country of ukraine
many of us are here
were born in ukraine we came to israel
many many years ago however there are
also friends here who are not from
ukraine originally okay and we all
protest against this against this
totalitarian
dictatorship which invades the sovereign
country i came tonight with all of my
friends my family my friends still in
ukraine it's warren ukraine we need your
help we need help from your european
nations from nato from all around the
world don't stay at home choose your
voice go out slav ukrainians
shiva
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
oh